I got two lovely bunch of coconuts
delete lost a lot of respect for myself
after that what's going on you back a
chance look at that [ __ ] did not do my
hair I don't do fun about to play some
basketball now one of the ways I like to
keep active is playing basketball I know
for a fact that I'm not that good at
ball but here's the thing I [ __ ] loner
I fractured my ankle
I'm 227 pounds you know what I am as
good as I used to be I've accepted that
fat but I'm gonna be straight up with
you there's a few type of people I
[ __ ] hate playing ball with and you
know who you [ __ ] are every man so
you already know what it is LG&E let's
get it oh it's been a while since I've
done that that should hurt number one
the ball ha that's right you ball
hogging [ __ ] dick sucking bit
every time the ball come for you like a
black hole that [ __ ] never come out I'll
be straight up with you if you're a ball
hog and you're like the dopest player on
earth you know what go ahead pop me is
about 98.6% the time for hogs [ __ ]
suck how many times I can read into a
ball hog that keeps on asking for the
ball what he can't even catch it cut him
up baby the ball and the moment he
touched the ball yeah like that was
butter on it a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
get your life together
listen just cuz you made about four shut
throughout the whole game doesn't mean
you're good you see you shut the ball
about 72 times the odds are not in your
favor [ __ ] so stumpy just full
passes ball to his own shadow [ __ ]
number to the couch you know that one
[ __ ] on the pickup team that
always wants to coach everybody listen
your coach Carter get the [ __ ] on out of
here
you're gonna figure with your rest setup
crappy on the flow how about you do the
world a favor and lay in the middle of
the freeway [ __ ]
number three foul guy listen when you
come to a street ball game there's no
such thing as fouls unless you're
[ __ ] bleeding or as flagrant as [ __ ]
every time you call a foul and it does
not need to be called it slows up the
your faul is not that important stop
being a little [ __ ] anyone else's
failed your [ __ ] breath you do gasps
mom I said what's the whole point of
calling the excessive files during the
game there's no prize at this you're not
going to the NBA I'm not good enough
you're not good enough and you [ __ ]
like 60 years old NBA's past number five
the I get angry at myself guy you know
who you are you are the guy that every
time you either lose a game or you [ __ ]
up
you got a condo scene and started
yelling at yourself you're [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] this is the guy that every
time he misses the shot he acts like he
never missed a shot before what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me god it's just not going
in nobody want to hear you complain is
bad enough when you yell at the other
teammates it's ten times more annoying
when you get yourself acting like a
[ __ ] weirdo yelling at your
reflection [ __ ]
the game is not that serious it's just
for fun and some of you guys get mad at
me because I'm like six foot one six two
and I can't [ __ ] dunk the ball why
are you surprised I'm gonna tell you
straight up right now you pick me up I
have breasts and I am fat what made you
think that I could constantly run down
the court this is your fault stupid do
not assess the situation properly if I
run and a titty flies in my mouth I just
might be I get in my face like why don't
you run down on that last play I'm fat
what is going on my pretty little babies
come in give me a hug let's do it so if
you guys have not noticed I have been
uploading three times a week that's
right funny fat bit on Wednesdays Friday
we have life loss which we are doing
another episode where I was in Hawaii so
please check that on Friday and if you
didn't see last week's or the weeks
before that go ahead and go to those
things because it's in the description
box below and of course as you guys know
I mentioned that I'm working on a short
film and yes it is going to be out on my
youtube broken up into three parts so I
hope you guys like it it's coming out
very soon so stay tuned for that
trailer coming soon to you - yes so
remember people stay hot stay sexy be
cool be nice whatever do it do it do it
do it go for broke right so remember
buddy
life is always what you make it but it's
up to you to take what you deserve
let's go for broke you want the last
time someone caught me a [ __ ] I walk
into a face I was like maybe I am